hey guys I'm out of the country at the
moment but we didn't want to leave you
hanging with no clips so here's just
some general Insanity of the day
I think there is a trans genocide okay
and I think it's you okay because you're
sterilizing a lot of these people how so
I mean you're literally sterilizing them
the surgery to remove the gonads
hysterectomies and cross-ex hormones and
puberty blockers have a high rate of
sterilization I mean first of all uh
removal of the gonads in the uterus is
an absolute sterilization and then
puberty blockers have a very high rate
uh and uh cross-ex hormones have
extremely high rate of sterilizing the
individual so these people can no longer
reproduce that's genocide
is this the joke you can go for joke you
are removing these people's ability to
reproduce and if they're a young age and
they haven't had the ability like for
instance Jazz Jennings can never have
kids jazz Jennings also and this this
probably part of your studies can't
actually feel any said like sexual uh
feeling of any kind do you have any idea
how weird this sounds right now like why
are you what about the stranger's
genital pleasure that's so weird that's
so bizarre that was very weird yourself
you guys are all right so I'm talking
about adults who engage in activities
which is a large portion of the global
economy whether you like it or not sex
cells they say and when I say this
person will never have this ability you
go how weird is that it's weird for you
to fixate on a stranger's genital
pleasure that's strange that's so
bizarre yeah she's public about it but
see that's you're not making an argument
right now is my point I'm not I'm saying
it's weird it's not an argument that's
an observation so you're trying to make
an appeal to emotion and an appeal I'm
just I'm just giving you my genuine
thought when you say something like that
that it was a really pathetic
why should we discuss whether or not she
has genital feeling that's not important
it's not that it's not in my business so
let's focus that on the sterilizing of
the individual are you okay with that
when who's sterilizing people Jazz
Jennings is sterile why are we going
back to Justin because yeah I don't know
anything about her because Jazz is a
famous individual on cable television so
if she is sterile for whatever reason
what does that have to do with me why
does that concern me why should I pass
the sterilization of teenagers
this is such a weird way to frame this
like you are removing teenagers ability
to have children I'm not doing anything
I'm not a doctor too
right I support people having access to
health care of course why would I want
to prevent that just because some people
have bigotry towards them let's try
again you seem scared of this do you
believe that parents and doctors should
have the ability to remove the ability
of a child for for future reproduction
they should have the ability to give
them access to health care of course
they should so why did you you're you're
implying that every single gender
affirming care results in sterilization
that is that is not true at all the
removal there's also people who are
trans that never get bottoms you seem
very scared of this it's scaring you how
am I afraid to because you keep
deflecting when I ask you so Jazz
Jennings is a specific team all right
let's try this all right let's slow down
and go one point at a time you think I'm
deflecting because I don't want to keep
talking about someone's genital pleasure
who's a stranger
things
not going to work on me I'm asking you a
sign I know I can appeal to your emotion